talking to the taliban sky news meets
the fighters gaining ground
in afghanistan as allied forces pull out
the uk's former spy chief tells us this
could be bad news
this is a crucial highway which the
taliban have been trying to get control
of
but the fact that the taliban have got
so close to
national capital
they're making gains
well i think if if terrorist groups are
allowed to regenerate
somewhere like afghanistan it will be it
will lead to more threat
on the shores of our country and our
allies
restoring people's freedoms the prime
minister to reveal plans on easing
restrictions later
amidst concern from some scientists
demolished u.s officials take down the
last
section of the collapsed miami apartment
building with more than 100 people still
missing
a very big thank you from the very top
the queen awards uk health services the
george cross
as the nhs prepares to mark its 73rd
birthday
and the wimbledon wild card wonder the
british teenage sensation emma raducano
prepares for her last 16 match at
wimbledon
good morning for many of us at sunshine
and showers but fewer showers in the
south van over the weekend and not as
heavy either
further north though still looking
rather unsettled and could turn very
windy later on
from the southwest more details through
the morning
[Music]
morning all we begin with a rare glimpse
inside the very heart
of taliban territory sky news is filmed
with fighters in afghanistan who are
gaining weapons and ground as the us
draws down its presence in the country
in the wake of the 9 11 attacks
thousands of international troops poured
in
to oust the taliban government for
harboring the al qaeda leader osama bin
laden
but nearly 20 years on foreign troops
have all but departed
the former head of mi6 sir alex younger
has told us the threat to the uk from
terror groups like al-qaeda will grow
if allies turn their back on the country
well sky news has spent time with the
taliban in this exclusive report
the team traveled from kabul to sadabad
south west of the capital
and then to an old u.s army base at
sultan kell
which has just been recently taken over
by the taliban
our special correspondent alex
crawford's report was filmed by kevin
shepard
the taliban are on the march and gaining
territory
at an astonishing rate
we've been invited to meet them inside
their own base
they want to show us as foreign
journalists how strong they are
and also how they're in no mood to
compromise
the departure of the bulk of the
american and other nato forces has
emboldened them and they smell
victory one commander in warduk province
told me they would never
work alongside the other groups in
government
as a real afghan we would never do that
because they are the people who are
killing and kidnapping
who are thieves and who are corrupt so
we'll never work with them
we're the first foreign journalists to
see the latest army base the taliban
have captured in the province
and they want to show us the treasure
trove of military riches they've seized
with it
many of these boxes supplied by the
americans hadn't even been opened before
the taliban got hold of them
can anyone believe that the taliban
wants peace when you've you've got all
these weapons now
most of the time we don't rely on all of
this we just rely on allah
but it does help us a lot and it's given
us a lot of new weapons we can use in
battle
of course we want peace more people want
peace here but the government doesn't
want peace with us
from this base alone the taliban say
they seized about
900 guns 30 humvees
and 20 army pickup trucks
the whole pile of of destroyed
vehicles military vehicles there and a
huge
area that they've managed to take over
i think this the taliban will see this
and view this as a substantial victory
and it follows a nationwide pattern of
afghan soldiers putting up only a
half-hearted fight
many of the fighters we saw were
carrying new weapons
seized during the taking of the base
the white flag that signifies the
taliban takeover is flying in large
swathes of the country right now
and they're creeping closer to the
capital
our journey on route to the taliban was
halted this is a crucial
highway which the taliban had been
trying to get control of
the afghan army brought in
reinforcements to push them back
but the fact that the taliban have got
so close to
the capital they're
making gains
the taliban are winning the propaganda
war able to plant
and detonate roadside bombs with few
reassurances from the government about
how they're going to regain
control instead in taliban controlled
areas
they blamed the afghan national army for
injuries and insecurity
we saw no women at all out in public
although the taliban insist they've
progressed
and want their girls educated do you all
welcome the taliban being here
tell me why
because it's so much safer now the
taliban have brought us security and
peace he says
the taliban paint themselves as deeply
religious
and say they're fighting for an islamic
emirate based on a strict interpretation
of sharia law
like so many others this former prisoner
jailed by the americans immediately
rejoined the fight on his release
the only thing that will persuade me to
put down my gun is if there's islamic
law here
based entirely on islam and the
government is run according to islamic
rules
the taliban resurgence appears to have
real momentum and that's worrying for
the afghan government and its
international allies
who are now watching all the military
hardware they handed over
ending up in the hands of the group
they're meant to be used against
the government is seen as weak and
deeply unpopular in areas
particularly where the taliban have
managed to take a hold
can you work with any of them they are
nothing anything
no nothing and this we will destroy
three
we are we are going to
uh destroy our country
they they come they bring a
bad bad situation for afghanistan
for our people for our civilized
for our country for our schools
for our hospitals everything they
destroyed
and this while peace talks are meant to
be ongoing and all the while the taliban
seem to be growing stronger
and that will surely lessen their desire
to do any deals
alex crawford sky news in wada province
and we're joined once again on the
programme by the care minister helen
waitland as well good to see you i do
hope you're well
and we will of course move straight on
to your brief in just a second but just
on
on afghanistan because this is a day of
of some significance
several hundred british lives have been
lost given that
the chaos that afghanistan is
experiencing in in some
parts was it worth it
well our involvement in afghanistan and
the involvement of our military has
reduced the threat to us
from al qaeda while we're withdrawing
from military engagement
we will continue to be supporting
afghanistan and what we want to see is a
peaceful and stable future for the
people of afghanistan that's what they
deserve
um now to your brief of course a very
big day we're expecting a significant
announcement from the prime minister
just a little bit later on which i am
certain
that you will not wish to preempt but
just in terms of the road map to july
the 19th is there anything in the data
as things stand that would make that
date anything other than set in stone
so as you mentioned there later today
the prime minister and the health
secretary
are going to be setting out our plans
for the next stage of the roadmap
where we're on track to take that final
fourth stage of the roadmap on july the
19th
giving people back far more of their
freedoms much more back
to normal and this is thanks to both the
sacrifices that people have made
but the huge success of the vaccination
program
and what we're seeing there is where the
vaccination program has really
weakened the link between people
catching covid
and ending up in hospital and then very
sadly those
the risk of dying what we're seeing is a
vaccination really making
a difference there so that's why the
prime minister will be able to set up
these plans with the health secretary
later today
it certainly has made a difference a
huge difference but
when reading the words of the of the
health secretary of the weekend the new
health sector your new boss sergeant
javid
suggesting that we will see a
significant rise in infections
uh when we reopen if it's on july the
19th or or on another date
to what extent are you expecting a rise
in
infections can you put a number on it
the ons thinks we're about one in 260
people
with covert in england at the moment
where will it go after july the 19th
that's absolutely true i don't have a
number for you but what we do anticipate
is we will continue to see
infections rise as we open up more as
people are going about
life more like normal but the important
thing here
is every day more people getting
vaccinated we're already in a position
where 86
of adults have had their first dose 63
have had their second dose we expect by
the 19th of july that'll be over
two-thirds of the adult population
having had their second dose
so that's far more protection from
covert and the message to anyone
watching this
is if you're an adult if you're over 18
and you haven't had your first job yet
go and get it
if you're eligible for your second job
go and get that two get the protection
that you can have
what it then is your message to people
this morning as about as regards
the wedding of masks after july the 19th
i mean will you be wearing one
so further um details are going to be
set out by the prime minister and the
health secretary
on that later today um of course i like
others
will plan to follow the guidance on when
you should or shouldn't
wear them we're going to be asking
people much more to take personal
responsibility
for choices like that i know like many
others i can't wait to
not have to wear a mask but you know i
will be cautious and and try and make
the right judgments and follow guidance
on this
sure but what on what basis should
people make
make that that decision i mean what are
the common sense places in which
you will find yourself continuing to
wear a mask we obviously know that
there are other cabinet colleagues
robert generic speaking at the weekend
suggesting that they they won't be
wearing one
well i think and others were saying like
i'm saying that we're looking forward to
not having to wear one in so many
circumstances
but one of the things that we will be
setting out later today health sector
the prime minister
is the findings of the social distancing
review looking at things like mask
wearing
and the one meter plus distance from
people
i can't preempt the detail of what's
going to be said later today
but overall what i can say is we're
going to be shifting much more to an
approach which is where there's guidance
but you take a personal responsibility
make a common sense judgment about what
is
the right thing to do to protect
yourself and others i'm just trying to
dig though down into
the idea of making common sense uh
judgments and all of this i mean public
transport for example
at the maid of greater manchester andy
burnham has pointed out the fact that
you know
there are vulnerable people who need to
take public transport to get to work
they don't have a choice
about how they get to work the people
who sit next to them
will have a choice as to whether or not
to wear a mask
should they be wearing a mask on a bus
well as i said i can't preempt what's
going to be set out later today
but a really important point here is
that
particularly those who are at the
highest question covert now have
the opportunity to get vaccinated when
the earlier cohorts invited
to be vaccinated so not only had the
first dose but also the second dose so
i've got a high level
of protection from the vaccination we're
seeing that
with both pfizer and astrazeneca the
protection from hospitalization
is over 90 so that's really strong
protection from being vaccinated
that's the best thing for those people
who are at higher risk
sure but but again i'm not asking you to
preempt the decision i'm just asking for
just some examples of where
one might you know display common sense
and wear the mask but just very
specifically
in terms of visiting care homes in terms
of visiting hospitals
if everything opens up on july the 19th
should we expect those
to open up in in the way it was pre-buck
pre-covered 19.
well with care homes and clearly there's
a particular risk to
residents and care homes who we know
have been much
more vulnerable to covid what we've done
over the last few months
as that group of people have been right
at the forefront of the vaccination
effort
is already open up and in fact reduced
some of the restrictions on visiting
again even on the 21st of june
we will be taking some more steps uh as
part of step four
of the road map i don't think visiting
will completely go back to normal there
will still have to be some
precautions but it's step by step
getting things as close to normal
as we can while still protecting people
at greater risk from cobit
just in terms of of a couple of the
measures that have helped people through
you know what have been that a
tremendously difficult year and a half
for all of us let's be absolutely honest
about it the extension to universal
credit
i mean it does sound like there are
divergent voices
within the cabinet on this and would you
be minded to see that uplift continue
just a little bit longer
as but people like you and duncan smith
have suggested
well i don't think i can go into the
detail of that but i mean what we do
know
is that we have some difficult times
ahead that this has been a huge hit to
our
economy and also that we have extra
costs so for instance i know very well
for the nhs that we're providing an
extra 7 billion of funding to help the
nhs through this year
including helping the nhs reduce the
backlog of people waiting for treatment
but we have both some real real cost
pressures and also some challenges for
the economy which we're going to have to
get through
how did it make you feel when you heard
of the news of
of your former colleague at the
department for health
uh matt hancock that he had broken the
rules that
that he had introduced
i mean i think it was a difficult moment
for me to see that like for
many others and also you know what
struck me was the huge sacrifices that
many people
have made during the pandemic all the
things that have been
missed whether it's children missing out
on education whether it's
grandparents not getting to see their
grandchild all the all the time that
hasn't been spent by people together
what matt hancock did was completely
wrong and he did the right thing by
resigning
did you feel angry about it because all
those people that you've just listed had
a genuine reason to feel angry
yeah and i think it's it's a very
difficult
moment when you have worked with
somebody through
the pandemic as the health team has
worked through that over the last 18
months
but he has resigned because he
recognizes
he did the wrong thing and my job
is to focus on looking ahead in
supporting
the nhs workforce and also social care
through the months ahead and of course
we have social care reform to get on
with as well
so there's a lot to do looking ahead and
that's what i'm focused on
helen waitley as i said before good to
see you again thanks for joining us this
morning
thank you plenty more still to come
on the show this morning uh us officials
have demolished the rest of that
miami apartment building that collapsed
11 days ago
around about half past we're going to be
speaking to someone whose friends
are still missing
[Music]
at 20 past eight we'll be getting the
views of sergeant tag member professor
callum semple
as the prime minister prepares to give
more details at the end of lockdown
measures in england
[Music]
i'll be speaking to the teen blues
singer toby lee
16 16.
[Music]
time for a look at the morning's other
main stories and as mentioned
officials have demolished the remaining
section of the collapsed miami apartment
building
in a controlled detonation the explosion
was carried out in part
due to concerns of high winds from
tropical storm
elsa rescue workers are awaiting the all
clear to resume their search
for the hundred plus people still
missing since they collapsed 11 days ago
the mayor of miami-dade county said she
was relieved
honestly this precise moment i feel
relief i feel relief because this
building was unstable the building was
hampering our search efforts
i've heard them say that they think
there are voids in this area areas where
they'll be able to search
let's take a look at the latest
coronavirus data for the uk
there were 24 at 200 and
new cases reported in the most recent
24-hour period
50 more deaths have also been reported
meaning the total number of people who
died within 28 days of a positive test
now stands at 128 two hundred
and twenty two the latest vaccination
figures show another one hundred and
thirty seven thousand three hundred and
eighty nine received their first
jab 196 thousand two hundred and nine
received their second in total 33.6
million people have now received
both doses of a covered vaccine
lockdown restrictions in northern
ireland are easing today with up to six
people
from five households permitted to meet
in a private setting
the number of people allowed to gather
outdoors is also increasing to 500
restrictions also being eased in the
republic of ireland today the limit on
the number of people who can visit each
other
if they're fully vaccinated or have
recovered from covert 19 in the last
nine months
has been removed pre-planned weddings
with a maximum of
50 people are also permitted
cities around the uk and stonehenge have
been lit up to celebrate the national
health service's
73rd year to mark the occasion the queen
has awarded
the george cross recognising the efforts
of health workers
it is only the third time the award has
been gifted to a collective group
and we'll be speaking to the national
medical director of nhs england
dr stephen paris at as you can see in
your screen half past
firefighters in cyprus are struggling to
contain
what's being described as the most
destructive wildfires in the island's
history
search crews recovered four bodies
outside the village of odu on the
southern edge of the trudus mountain
range
the president of the european council
has now promised to provide
every kind of assistance to help people
through the crisis
now thousands of england fans will be
hoping to secure tickets
to what could prove to be a historic
semi-final
after the three lions defeated ukraine
in rome on saturday
but what's all this about well as you
can see the team playing around in a
swimming pool with some
inflatables that you might just
recognize from well 2018 the world cup
back then
relaxing after what's been a meteoric
rise
through the competition and they are of
course taking on denmark
for a shot at the finals on wednesday
the lifeguards
must be having an absolute canary uh now
time for a quick
look through the front pages uh let's
start with the sun
it links the goodwill towards the
england football team with the
happiness that many people are likely to
feel at the loosening of restrictions
the government prepares to make
anti-covert measures uh like
masquerading and
social distancing a matter of personal
responsibility
rather than law the mail proclaiming
freedom is in your hands now
according to the guardian the government
is facing a backlash
from some of its scientific advisers who
disagree with the change in policy
meanwhile the ft has word that china's
internet regulator
has banned the taxi app didi for
allegedly violating rules and personal
data collection
now let's return now to our top story
the withdrawal of troops from
afghanistan
the former head of mi6 sir alex younger
has told sky news that groups like
is and al-qaeda have the capacity to
regenerate in the country which
in turn could lead to an increased
threat
to the uk uh as you can see he was
speaking to our foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes who joins us in the
studio good to see you this morning
deborah um
i i suppose in a sense if you've been
following what is happening on the
ground in afghanistan at the moment
at these comments from sir alex are not
necessarily
entirely surprising no and and also if
you've been following
what's been going on in afghanistan you
might be surprised that despite the
the fact that we haven't had any
official words from the british
government the majority of british
troops have actually
already left the country along with the
rest of nato forces and
the reason they went in in the first
place was after the 9 11 attacks
in 2001 on the united states to
disrupt that terrorist threat and the
warning is now that if they leave
that that threat will return and that's
exactly what the former head of mi6 said
i think we can hear his words
the reality is that there are groups
there we've been very successful in
disrupting both
daesh and al qaeda they're on the back
foot
but they i will be wrong patently
declaring that they have gone away
and they have the capacity to regenerate
if terrorist groups are allowed to
regenerate
somewhere like afghanistan it will be it
will lead to more threat
on the shores of our country and our
allies
and his core message was that at the end
of the soviet
invasion of afghanistan when they drew
out in 1989
the west he said turned their back on
that country
and that led to the ability of al qaeda
to reject
to operate there in the first place and
he said it would be an enormous mistake
if the west did that again a really
significant warning from someone who
spent the last 20 years
at the heart of this fight against
terrorism um deborah much more from you
throughout the day i'm sure affinity
thanks very much indeed
there will be in-depth coverage on the
states of the country america is leaving
behind throughout the day today
including a special program with mark
austin at
7 p.m that is afghanistan end game today
a little later on sky news now it is a
big day at wimbledon for the british
teenager
emma radicane our sports presenter
jackie beltran
joins us from the glass box jackie
good to see you this morning it's it's a
fantastic story this one
oh it is it's she's arrived just at the
right time you know everyone's saying it
old murray's out and he's
maybe coming to the end of his career
and suddenly this star arrives
from absolutely nowhere well not quite
nowhere because she has been on the
lta the lawn tennis association's radar
and been supported by them for
many years since she was very small my
son used to play tennis and whenever
they would go to a tournament when they
were nine if anyone drew emma radicanu
it was a bit like
ooh bad luck you're not gonna win that
one she's always whacked the ball so
very hard
and has always had that great sort of
competitive spirit nothing seems to
to worry her even when she was down in
her previous matches or had a little bit
of a wobble
she regrouped and she just showed a lot
of experience that she doesn't actually
have and that
is very telling of a new player if they
can deal with the pressure deal with the
crowd deal with all of it
and it doesn't upset their game that is
a very good omen i have been
chatting to some of britain's top
coaches
at the weekend and even they are
surprised at how well it's gone for her
it is the stuff that dreams are made of
making it to the last 16 of wimbledon
on your debut and as a wild card at 338
in the world emma radhakanu is by far
the lowest ranked player in the draw
and the youngest british woman to reach
the fourth round of the championships in
the open era
everyone in the sport is impressed it's
massive
um you know having players like emma
it's so exciting it's exciting for
tennis of course it's exciting for
british tennis
she's going to grab a new audience and
just the way she's been on the court you
know she expresses herself
she gets the crowd involved she's
getting fired up and of course the
actual quality of tennis
is there for everyone to see
this might seem like an overnight
success story but it isn't
emma has been on the lta's high
performance program since she was a
youngster
she's coached by andy murray's
father-in-law nigel sears
and managed by maria sharapova's agent
but no one expected to be this
comfortable at the top table of world
tennis
just weeks after finishing her a-levels
and turning professional
the performance on the weekend was so
impressive for that reason you have to
remember emma was
playing her first wimbledon she only
played her first wta tour event three
weeks ago
so for her to go out and handle that
pressure was hugely impressive
she's handled a spotlight as if she was
born to it
there's a real buzz around here about
her next match it's against the world
number 75 australia's alia tomlianovich
and it is winnable as she was leaving to
join the player bubble a couple of weeks
ago her parents suggested she was
packing too many
match outfits as it turns out she didn't
pack enough
well hopefully she found a laundry and
even if she loses this next match she's
going to pick up 181 000
which is three times the amount of money
that she's earned in her career so far
but for her it won't be about that it'll
be about the experience
and learning and of course she'll be
back on that tour because her ranking's
pretty low
into some very far-flung places in very
low level tournaments
after this it will be back down to
reality with the bump uh also to today
roger federer
going so well at wimbledon much better
than expected after a knee injury and of
course novak djokovic
who has looked unbeatable
thanks very much emma what a prospect
for the future
uh time to see how the weather is
looking here's kirsty
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we have got some
interesting weather to talk about for
the start of the week it is going to
settle down later in the week
but tonight we've got wet and windy
weather moving from the south west and
today
for many it's a pretty showery picture
especially across central and northern
parts of the uk
so northern england scotland and
northern ireland we've got some heavy
showers to watch out for
further south we've got some brighter
skies there will be some showers around
but
not quite as heavy as the weekend you'll
be glad to hear so maybe a greater
chance
of seeing something a little bit drier
and brighter temperatures from high
teens into the low
20s so pleasantly enough in the sunshine
the showers though keep going further
north even where the skies brighten up
so it could be again some really heavy
downpours to watch out for there's some
really heavy thunderstorms yesterday in
the edinburgh area in the south
the calm before the storm in comes a low
pressure system as we move through the
evening
now it's going to be quite unseasonably
windy for the time of year as we go
through the night tonight
risk of gails along english channel
coast and rain spreading its way
northwards through the night
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
kirsty thanks very much indeed uh let's
return though to one of our one of the
big stories of the day one which will
develop through the day in fact
boris johnson will be revealing later
how he plans to restore people's
freedoms in england
in the final stage of his road map out
of lockdown here's helen whaley
of course i like others will plan to
follow the guidance on when you should
or shouldn't
wear them we're going to be asking
people much more to take personal
responsibility
for choices like that i know like many
others i can't wait to
not have to wear a mask but you know i
will be cautious and
try and make the right judgments and
follow guidance on this
uh well i also asked the care minister
what the the next stage of
opening up might mean for care homes and
care home visits
clearly there's a particular risk to
residents and care homes who we know
have been much more vulnerable to covid
what we have done over the last few
months as that group of people have been
right at the forefront of the
vaccination effort is already
open up and in fact reduced some of the
restrictions on visiting again even on
the 21st of june
we will be taking some more steps uh as
part of step four
of the road map i don't think visiting
will completely go back to normal there
will still have to be some
precautions um but it's step by step
getting things as close to normal as we
can
while still protecting people at greater
risk from covert
our political correspondent tamara cohen
joins me in the studio morning tc
and what did we learn from the care
minister this morning well i think the
main thing was to effectively confirm
that freedom day in england is happening
we've had all the
indications but the government aren't
supposed to be officially confirming it
until next monday that the 19th of july
will go ahead but she said
it's happening and that will mean as you
put to her masks
no longer mandatory you no longer have
to check in with your qr code
every time you go to a bar or restaurant
and we'll also be getting the results of
that review on social
distancing so we're expecting the
government to say that that one meter
plus rule
which has made it very difficult to have
full capacity in offices and restaurants
and other venues
will be swept away as well so a lot of
going back to normal
will be happening on the 19th but
questions i'm sure for boris johnson
about why
he and his health secretary have said we
need to live with it like we do with flu
i think we know what they're getting at
in terms of you vaccinate people and of
course
um we are going to get cases and we are
going to get some deaths but we're going
to
try and keep that as low as possible but
scientists are saying this isn't really
like flu
what's the data on how many cases is
acceptable
and where we will not go fully back to
normal is
care home visits and hospital visits and
also i'm not expecting the government to
say
look everyone back to the office
tomorrow morning i think to some extent
they will leave
up to employers to decide how fast they
want to go tomorrow thanks very much
indeed
now the partially collapsed apartment
building in miami has now been
demolished
due to concerns over storm elsa
24 people have died and the further 121
are missing from the disaster 11 days
ago
arnie and miriam notkin residents of
champlain towers
have still not been found despite the
efforts of one of arnie's
former students uh i'm pleased to say
that that sonia diaz
uh joins us on the programme sonia
really appreciate you taking the time to
be with us this morning thanks
thanks very much for being with us and i
just wonder if you might start
no no not a problem i just wonder if you
might start by telling us just a little
bit
about arnie and miriam
well i met arne when i was in elementary
school
it was back in 1974. he was our our
elementary school
uh physical education teacher he was a
fun guy to be with everybody loved him
he
his the kids were always hanging out
with him if
if they wanted to stay after school arne
was there
and so it was like he created this bond
with all the kids
and eventually over the years i stayed
there in elementary school until 1976
and then i moved on to middle school
high school graduated went on and then i
started working for the school system
where he and i worked together he worked
part-time by then and he worked with me
also at the miami beach police athletic
league
and it was uh we had
many many years of friendship and
and and just pretty much a nice guy to
be with
to hang out with the top two and you
know as years went on we kind of
took our ways and i had to move away
from florida and
i'd go back down there and i talked to
him i just talked to him maybe about a
year and a half ago when i was down
there last
so the fact that he's not been uh
recovered from
uh the rubble which is you know at this
point
i know that it's it's a done deal but
it's just heartbreaking to know that
something like this could happen and and
they haven't recovered his body or
or his wife's body i i i'm sorry to hear
you speak in those terms about about the
recovery rather than the rescue but with
the controlled detonation of another
part of the building that
there does look like there is very
little hope left for the
well for the 100 plus people still
missing yeah
yeah there i believe now there's about
126 missing
and this evening at 10 30 this evening
local time
they finally demolished the rest of the
control demolish but yet sad that they
they did that and and folks are
concerned about the fact that they still
haven't found
um a lot of people
and and you know it's hard to say
whether they were away whether they were
here but at this point
i i just tend to believe that it's it's
done and over with
as you say i mean you know the area very
well you know the couple very well
looking at what has happened in terms of
the rescue efforts over the past few
days
that the length of time that it has
taken um you know search and rescue to
to get in there i mean how has that made
you and
and others with with strong connections
to the area how has that made you feel
uh it's it's sad i i honestly
i it's like a gut punch
um i've talked to a lot of former
classmates that are
uh basically feeling the same way i mean
this happened
the night before my birthday and i'll
tell you it was just the saddest thing
to hear
wake up on my birthday morning to hear
that this happened and
and so many lives have been lost i mean
i
i i'm sad about my friends but i'm sad
about everybody that's
that's you know and even the pets i mean
i'm i'm just heartbroken there's just no
other way to
to call it it's just heartbreaking well
if if if it is any consolation i suspect
it will not be this is a story that has
been reported
in every corner of the world there have
been billions of eyes
on what has happened there i think
plenty of people feel a connection to
an apartment block like that coming down
with well with what some would say
was absolutely no notice
absolutely not 1 30 in the morning
everybody's asleep in their beds
and and just the first day when i saw
the the news and i saw that
side of the building is all gone and you
see kids beds you see
just bedrooms and and it's just
yeah that's the collapse of the rest of
the building today
so yeah that's a little gut-wrenching
i i i i want to finish if we can sonia
just just once again as well i'll see if
my director can show us the pictures of
of arnie and miriam again because i
think in every single one of those
pictures
the pair of them have the broadest smile
that you could ever possibly see
it strikes me in their lives
that's all you ever saw was them and and
the one on the balcony that
i believe that was the last last may
this past may that they celebrated his
birthday and
or the balcony one i believe was in
covid last year and
um yeah that's that was a smiling group
they they were always smiling
um well sonia i we will keep fingers
crossed that there may well be some
miracle for some people
um as regards the situation in florida
but um
we can only hope yeah indeed um so
thanks very much for taking the time to
talk to us really appreciate it
thank you
no the uk must cut its global
environmental footprint by
75 by 2030 according to a new report by
the world wildlife fund the wwf joining
us now mark wright
director of science at the worldwide
fund for nature
mark great to have you on the program
this morning um
explain exactly what what what this must
what this means for the uk if we suggest
that we need to see our environmental
footprint cut by 75
what sort of world will be living in
okay well let's remember why we're
asking for this in the first place and
it's quite clear that
all the things we buy the food we eat
are fueling the loss of nature and also
increasing the risk of climate change so
clearly something has to be done
so we're calling for a three-quarter
slashing of our footprint let's remember
this is
just what's happening in the uk it's
also kind of
factors in the things we import from
overseas as well the food we bring from
oc's the clothes the cars and so on
but what's what the report also says is
basically speaking there's a lot of
flexibility in the system we can make
those changes there's really substantial
changes without
massively impacting our lives so don't
forget the government has already
committed to a 78
reduction in greenhouse gases so these
things are perfectly doable
and actually the economy could benefit
as a result as well
give us some examples of though mark
because frankly it will be music to
everyone's ears if we can we can make
those type of gains in terms of our
environmental impact
without there being a corresponding and
equally significant effect on well
frankly let's be selfish about
our own lives okay well let's use food
because we know that food is a real
driver for
losses around the world so in this
country it might be surprised to hear
that
we waste about 10 million tons of food
and drink
every single year 10 million tons so
just think about what it costs to do so
in terms of time
resources processing transport and so on
so it's horrifying that we we waste 10
million tons
but 70 of that is perfectly edible so if
we could kind of
rework the system so that we're not kind
of throwing this stuff away
and of course that 30 percent is none
edible for us
is edible for plenty of other things for
example insects and they're really good
systems
up and running already to take food
waste
feed it to insects and then we feed
those insects to chickens
rather than giving them soy which came
from latin america
and it was produced by cutting down
rainforest and clearing grasslands and
so on so there's a real
win-win situations though what are the
consequences what are the potential
consequences that would follow from us
not being so ambitious in our
our targets to reduce our environmental
impact
well i think the images you're showing
here show us the impacts i mean only
these last couple of years we've seen
just extraordinary outbursts of
you know fires around the world you know
the horrible fires missing in british
columbia at the moment
ficus i saw yesterday but yeah siberia
amazon australia we're seeing these
extreme weather events they those will
become the norms sadly
and we know that we're losing species
around the world as well and
don't forget since 1900 if 500 types of
vertebrates have gone extinct so these
are animals
no one will ever see again and that
those those risks will increase
as if we don't take action now mark
wright
good to see you this morning thanks very
much for being with us
okay well let's return now to our
special coverage of the allied drawdown
of troops from
afghanistan u.s troops have almost
completed their pull-outs after a
conflict that has cost them
and of course the afghan people dearly
afghan civilians have suffered huge loss
of life more than
47 000 have been killed at since 2001.
while the afghan government keeps the
army's death toll secret to avoid
damaging morale
estimates show that between 66 and 69
000 afghan soldiers have also been
killed
more than 2 400 u.s soldiers at 455
uk soldiers and military personnel have
been killed in action
and the war has now cost an approximate
2.261 trillion
dollars well a recent study said that
british soldiers were
twice as likely to be killed as u.s
troops mainly
because they were patrolling in the
highly dangerous helmand province
james matthews reports now and how lives
were changed forever
by one terrifying incident
leaving afghanistan doesn't mean
afghanistan leaves there
soldiers who served like stuart pearson
and families who waited back home like
bob and jen
wright the parents of mark i used to say
well but if you go out
any and there's any trouble hide behind
the biggest tree
i'm in afghanistan mum there's no any
big trees
you've got a man marking stewart's
horrific story has been graphically
depicted on the big screen
even impossible due to location being
minefield
with colleagues the two friends became
trapped in a minefield
after going in to help a fellow soldier
who'd stood on a mine
of four explosions the second took off
stewart's left leg
i took my foot off a rock my left foot
and put it on the ground and that's when
i
that's when i heard the explosion um i
get
blown up slightly and twisted round the
soldiers have called for a helicopter
with a winch
to lift out casualties and relative
safety but they were told none was
available
the downdraft from a landing chinook set
off another mine
unfortunately mark he was straddling
over me protecting me from the
down blast of the helicopter he got
blasted
by that injuries to his face neck and
upper body
mark wright survived the first explosion
that caught him he was badly injured
but continued to communicate on the
radio and with critically injured
colleagues
i remember just lining her thinking i
don't know if i can hold on for another
hour here
but mark wasn't i was wanting to fall
asleep but mark wouldn't let anyone
fall asleep he was shouting at us after
four hours u.s blackhawk helicopters
arrived at the site near afghanistan's
kajaki dam
and winched the casualties to safety
four mines had injured eight
soldiers mark wright was hit twice
as mark was getting winched up by the
blackhawks and then shouted down
tell julian and my family that i love
them
every night when he was way before he
went to sleep always here i love you
i always thought i did if i'm dead in
the morning
that was the last words i heard and i
mean when he used to phone
he always says bye i love you
i thought god i cried that's over then i
looked upside my mark was
lying there and i looked again and
paramount if i rolled on top
and gave him cpr and then i looked again
at me and
it was gone
just took the breath away i just thought
that's our life over
at the inquest into my right's death the
coroner called him an exceptional
soldier
whose death was down to a series of
failures a lack of appropriate
uk helicopters with a winch the
downdraft from the chinook
and the delay in sending an appropriate
helicopter
i'd say a lot of these decisions are
just made by the maybe people who sits
in whitehall that have never
fought a battle at all taken one day and
fought an enemy so
um quite you know quite a quite
disgusted bite yeah
why did they go there in the first place
everywhere they go they never seemed to
finish the job
and that's some pulling out what about
these lives that were lost
sad james matthews sky
news dal keith
well in recent weeks negotiators from
the afghan government and the taliban
have been meeting in qatar's capital
doha
to discuss the peace process after talks
had
previously stalled earlier in the year
uh joining us now is fazir kufi a member
of the afghan government's peace
negotiating team
who was also the country's first deputy
first female deputy speaker
of parliament ms kofi great to have you
on the program this morning really
appreciate you taking the time
um as we see western troops
removing themselves almost entirely from
afghanistan
what state do they leave your country in
while we do uh appreciate and there is a
huge
sympathy and complements to the
long-term partnership we have had
with international community on this uh
uh uh joint uh threat the common threat
which was the international
military extremism that the people of
afghanistan of course were in the
forefront
with the international community i guess
it's more or less uh
the same situation when they came to
afghanistan uh
20 years back in terms of um you know
money money
indicators many many benchmarks if you
look it's almost the same
yes things have changed we have a
government
institutions are there um you know there
is a
security institutions money progress on
women's rights etc
but if you look at the whole situation
in terms of uh you know
still the risks for military extremism
is there
at the risk of institution once again
being
the victim of collapsing is there the
the risk for
you know uh losing some of these gains
are there as you say i mean
things look from a certain angle to to
not have changed particularly the last
time i was in afghanistan reporting from
afghanistan was
was 10 years ago and back then we were
talking about
training up the afghan national army
training up the ansf
so that afghans could police their own
country
you look at what is happening in various
parts of afghanistan at the moment and
it would appear that the government does
not have that capacity
yeah with the rapid change that is uh
now you see
happen in afghanistan at least in some
parts of the country
i don't think this is because the
taliban or the other military extremists
are strong i think
much of the situation the responsibility
goes to the fact that um
you know we have not been able to really
demonstrate a strong leadership in terms
of getting the
holding the country together um you know
this the army as
it was expected to be a well-trained
well-equipped um
along with other security institutions
we see that they
are not really taking up their
responsibility in many parts of the
country
um they actually leave the area without
any threat without
any serious risk being um faced
to them so um yes um i think
um that the problem was that in many uh
villages uh the international troops
actually fought on behalf of these
security forces and that left
that sense of responsibility um you know
away from the shoulders of the
the security institutions and the
leadership many
internal factors uh contribute to the
fact that
where we are now and i think um
things would have been much better if uh
the leadership
could take more responsibility if
corruption was for instance
tackled in a way that um you know the
security
uh for soldiers could benefit from the
aids
um these these different elements put
hands together and
where we are we are where we are now and
i must say also the the rule and the
uh the significance of the the
propaganda the
the propaganda for instance there was a
report which indicated that afghan
government will collapse in six months
that of course uh uh automatically
uh um not only the security but also the
people
um what what then of events taking place
where you are the the efforts to secure
some kind of
negotiated peace with the taliban how
much hope do you place in that given
that which you've just been discussing
well i i i'm still hopeful that there
will be um
only one solution and that is a
negotiated settlement i believe that
even if either side try to gain more
territory and try to control more places
uh via a military um strategy
that is not going to be sustainable
that's not they're not going to sustain
it
um how for instance if taliban can try
to control more
uh territory how are they going to
finance and govern there
um so that's going to be extremely
difficult and even if they try to
by whatever means control the cities
bigger cities
of course the governance will be a major
issue and there will be
a military um i think uh you know
uh resistance against them from
different local communities probably
not very organized uh and that is the
concern
but eventually they will be organized
let's remember that
20 years back when you know after the
boon conference the new government was
established
nobody actually even talked about
taliban taliban was completely dead
but after the iraq war taliban emerged
because the attention was focused to
iraq
and taliban emerged four years later so
even if once i try to
win militarily that is not going to end
the war
so therefore i think the only hope is
this political
settlement we are moving not very in a
in a fast
a pace unfortunately um because of
course um you know taliban and on
on both side i mean now talk what what
more than peace
we are hoping that um in the next few
months that before uh
kind of the deadline for withdrawal we
will be able to reach some kind of
political agreement
well we wish you all the very best of
luck with with those efforts fawzia kofi
great to see you this morning thanks for
being with us
time for us to see how the weather's
looking this week here's kirsty
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning the weather's staying
fairly unsettled for the start of the
week but things will calm down towards
the weekend
just in time for my birthday of course
but in the meantime looking rather
unseasonable and windy tonight
we have got some drier brighter spells
across southern parts of england and
wales and ireland to start the day
further north though still quite cloudy
with showery rain for northern england
northern ireland and scotland could be
some heavy rain still for a time
across northern areas so some heavy
showers and even a few rumbles of
thunder in the north
fewer showers certainly compared to the
weekend and a bit more sunshine in the
south
temperatures up to 22 degrees but
tonight we've got wet and windy weather
moving up from the southwest